portions of the following ABC special
program have been pre-recorded the 49th
Annual Academy Awards live from the
Dorothy Chandler Pavilion of the Music
Center in Los Angeles California
bidding you welcome and Margaret
so
and it's
is fine
a magic
well the No
tender
as round as it is
when he color
it's blue
in
makes the play
otherwise da ha
and empty school
if it winds up to
the large or small
Naser cocaine
in clueless
remember watch it's bed it all began in
someone's head
remember we watch it spread it all began
in someone's
how do
there's brought to life
coquettes life just
and by slips because it swiftly
your taste for quality and by Polaroid
makers of the sx-70 alpha one at the new
mondo camera
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
Walter Parrish
good evening ladies and gentlemen it's
once again my great pleasure to welcome
you tonight marks the 49th consecutive
year that members of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences have
given awards for excellence in
filmmaking tonight also begins a
year-long celebration commemorating the
first 50 years of the Academy which was
founded in May of 1927 its stated
purpose at that time was to promote and
recognize excellence in all areas of
motion pictures after a half-century
that is still its purpose like any other
art or industry picture-making has had
periods of great fertility as well as
disturbing dry spells but over the years
the power of the movie screen to
entertain to enlighten and to enthrall
has grown rather than diminished without
question the incentives which the
Academy has provided have contributed
greatly to the finest achievements of a
motion picture screen over the past
half-century
the record has been a remarkable one the
titles of the Academy honoured film
speak for themselves and by honored I
mean the nominees as well as the winners
and so we 4,000 filmmakers of the
Academy begin our golden anniversary
celebration and we will renew the pledge
of our founders we will reflect upon our
past and we will create new programs to
assure that the next 50 years of film
will be even more innovative and
exciting than the past half century has
been and now to start the awards program
Richard Pryor
I'm here tonight to explain why no black
people will ever be nominated for
anything
black people love to act we can cry at
the drop of a hat
oh haha these are some of the things
black people can do we're also going to
stop entertaining that will show you we
refuse to be in show business all
together we are quitting then see who
sings and dances for you you have to
listen to Lawrence Welk forever try to
Boogaloo the neck but seriously when we
cut to the audience and you win we don't
want to see you mouthing anything like
that
the shores going up to 75 million people
none of them are black we don't even
know how to vote there's three thousand
three hundred and forty nine people in
the voting thing and only two black
people Sidney pottier and Harry
Belafonte in here to explain the voting
here to explain the voting is my friend
Chevy Chase
Edea Calvary on deaconship
is this the rehearsal or oh they're
really so many people I want to thank
I don't know where to begin producer
William freaking or bill as I like to
call him director Marty pasetta or Marty
as I like to call him of course my
godmother Aldo ray
just kidding just want to loosen you up
a bit make sure that you're all relaxed
and as the wiped out as you all are
let's get serious for one moment shall
we the winner in the category of
strangest film remake in 1976 - sir with
like no strange name
not very funny though that a hail
covered up again just wanted to loosen
everybody up and get as much camera time
as I can as you know I have been asked
to explain the Academy's nominating and
voting procedures it's a very big deal
for me according to the regulations of
the Federal Communications Commission
for those trivia buffs out there who may
not know exactly who the Federal
Communications Commission is composed of
I might briefly add that the founders of
the Commission were the very
distinguished pinky Lee Hart Fleming and
of course Rod Laver once again just
trying to get North Carroll
Ernest Borgnine ladies and gentlemen
Ernie let's give another hand okay Ernie
apparently you didn't hear about the
hair on the palms of your hand earlier
I'll be right with you this shouldn't be
more than 15 minutes this is I can make
this is an invitation to Tippi Hedren
party later and I will not be able to
make a movie it's not to read this way
it is here in fact are the rules all
eligible Academy members are asked to
vote for nominations for picture of the
year the other nominations are made by
members of each Academy branch or
special committees then all active
academy members vote by secret ballot
for all the awards of merit and furnish
their ballots to the Academy's
independent accountants for tabulations
documentaries and short subjects are the
sole exceptions I alone will choose
those winners according to my rule
actually that's a lie only active
members who attend special screenings
may vote for those particular awards
results are known only to Price
Waterhouse and of course their wives and
kids and black and company until the
sealed envelopes are open here before
you even as I have finished speaking
in conclusion allow me to demonstrate
the correct and accepted procedure for
opening the envelopes containing the
winners names this would be the
incorrect method ok the correct method
of course again incorrect just trying to
get more camera time
the only other FCC regulation I've been
asked to explain is the correct way to
give an acceptance speech should you be
lucky enough to be chosen by mr. and
mrs. Waterhouse there are we in
commercial there will be no fake crying
no boring and self-indulgent hugging and
kissing no gum chewing and losers who
are seen on camera during the
announcement of their loss are required
not to applaud the winners
good-naturedly to swear and leave Bronx
cheer would be fine
loud expletives such as I'm through with
motion pictures but ever last of all the
actual handling and fondling of the
Oscar itself must be limited to the
upper torso only unless it's after 10
o'clock
thank you very much and may you all
break legs
to introduce